just before the break we told you about
a Boston DEA candidate named Rachel
Rollins and her vision for criminal
justice reform what is the argument in
favor of her plan we're grateful at
Rachel Rollins agreed to come on this
show and make the case directly and she
joins us now Rachel thank you for coming
on I'm a lot of people are talking about
this story and I'm thankful that you are
here to tell us your views and because
I'm grateful I want to be respectful of
you and I'm gonna try to be I'm
concerned though and confused why in the
middle of the worst drug crisis in our
history you would want to decriminalize
possession with intent to distribute
drug dealing why well I'm talking well
first of all thank you so much for
having me on the show I'm very excited
to be the Democratic nominee here in
Boston I'm more concerned about
possession possession charges with
respect to substances and what we have
is a significant opioid crisis here in
Boston with six to eight people dying a
day and what we're seeing tucker is have
is people are being incarcerated and
they are having their opioid crisis
dealt with by the prison system or the
House of Corrections and I don't believe
that that's the appropriate place where
they should be getting I understand
that's I mean there's a counter-argument
but I think that's legitimate that is an
argument that you just made but on your
website unless I miss reading it it's
possession with intent to distribute
that's drug dealing so this crisis is
real you just said it why would we not
want to prosecute drug dealers in the
middle of a drug crisis well there's
there's significant smaller amounts with
respect to the intent to distribute
we're talking more along the lines of a
trafficking charge is where I'd be
wanting to focus our attention we have
deep we have removed mandatory minimums
Tucker in Massachusetts and a new new
criminal justice reform bill that was
signed into law by Governor Baker so we
are moving away from focusing on those
type of crimes I believe that what we're
doing here in Massachusetts at least and
I'm not sure what's happening where you
are located but there's lots of
non-violent people that are currently
sitting in jail and it's costing
over 50,000 at sometimes upwards of
$65,000 a year to have them there and
when they come out as you know Tucker
they have a felony they can't get
housing they can't get employment and
that's why we have over 50% recidivism
up here I mean for sure I mean that's
one but when I think when 70,000
Americans are dying year of drug Odie's
drug dealing it could be construed as a
form of violence let me ask you about
the shoplifting question you want to
decriminalize shoplifting so most people
who own convenience stores are poor
people a lot of them are immigrants what
do you say to them when they come to you
and say people are looting my store
essentially and no one will prosecute
them what's your answer to them so what
I what I want to make sure is no one's
saying that they aren't going to be held
accountable what I want to make sure
your your understanding is as I said
50,000 dollars a year to house somebody
in the Suffolk County House of
Corrections a shoplifting charge is
going to have multiple court dates we
are going to have let's say three months
this person can't afford their bail it's
going to cost us $12,500 to house them
in the Suffolk County House of
Corrections I believe that we can have
them doing either community service or
returning the item itself I think we
have to think creatively about solutions
it's much more fiscally responsible
tonight rouse them within go ahead but
both in both cases with the drug dealer
and the shoplifter you appealed to the
person being accused what happens to
this person it's very tough on the on
the criminal and I think it's a fair
point but you haven't seen anything
about about the parents of the kid who
died of a fentanyl OD or the shop owner
who's watching his stock get stolen by
shoplifters which is really common in
places as you know what do you say to
them
we're not cracking down as hard on the
people who are looting your store we're
not cracking down as art of the people
who killed your kid with fentanyl like
what's your line to them well what I
would say is certainly if there's an
opioid or overdose related death that's
a different situation that would could
be charged with a different crime that's
number one what I will say to you though
is with respect to the store owners
we're not saying that they're not going
to get their items back if we are
catching these individuals and return
the items and have a stay-away order and
that individual continues to go back
I'm saying Tucker is what happens now is
one incident occurs somebody is arrested
they usually can't afford their bail so
they're held pretrial it's costing us
more money if we can get a Civic
Association or some other oversight
involved in this individuals life and
get the services back to the or the the
items back to the store owner I think
that's a more responsible me you keep
saying fiscally responsible Boston is
now a livable city because the crime
rate is at its lowest in 20 years I
think and that's true of a lot of cities
the prime rate will go up if you get
elected and if people with your ideas
get elected nationwide there's really no
question we've seen it before what's the
cost of that when New York becomes a
place you can't live because of crime
when it becomes uninhabitable as it was
before in the 70s what's the cost that I
would I would challenge you a livable
city in the in what sense that you can
afford to live here but you don't get
mugged you go to the liquor store at
night as you used to in New York in 1981
people didn't live there Washington DC
same thing I lived there at the time you
couldn't go anywhere because of yeah
that's coming back in it are you worried
about that well I'm pushing back a
little on that Tucker respectfully I
believe there are sections in Boston
there's a three-mile radius where we
have over a thousand unsolved homicides
and the Washington Post just did an
article I'm sure you read where
Massachusetts sadly in Suffolk County
Boston we have the highest rate of
unsolved homicides with respect to a
racial disparity so I would push back a
little bit there are sections in Boston
that are not livable at all I want to
focus on that type of crime my I need to
push and make sure you understand I am a
former prosecutor I don't have a problem
putting people in jail if they are
violent but I believe we have too many
people in jail that are not violent and
we can disagree with what violence's and
I respect that and understand it but I
believe that we are spending too much
time again on petty crimes that are
clogging up our system and costing us
more money and we can handle them in a
more social they're more hopefully your
items then they aren't consumes a lot of
people have right okay we're out of time
right here you start going on no no
that's it we're we're just out of time
but I appreciate your coming on and
explaining your views thank you
you bet thank you